the the notion of the arizona cardinals
trading josh rosen is still lingering
out there the giants reportedly are
considering all options as the future
successor to eli manning including a
trade for josh rosen i saw that joel
clatt from fox was suggesting that there
are three teams that are in the running
for a josh rosen trade now i always
wonder when it's somebody who isn't one
of their football people who gets this
information is it coming from rosen's
camp yeah
a southern california guy that's been
around these ucla and usc teams a lot so
he's getting it from somebody with
direct knowledge that would make me
believe
so rosa so this is coming from rose and
then
this is originating with rose and ending
up with clatt i think so somewhere along
those lines certainly but yes i mean uh
i would think that you know fox sports
is in
southern california as you know as well
uh so yeah i would think that it's
coming from someone maybe not from rosen
but maybe he knows someone that's close
to rosen's camp that knows of the
situation so uh that makes sense but get
back to what you said mike he said
there's three teams that are interested
is that what he said i just want to make
sure i heard you correctly yeah clap
clad identified three teams i'll i'll
find it while you're talking go ahead
yeah okay well i guess the the first
thing that jumped out to me and i said
this when we were on tv a little bit is
you know when i hear this especially
when it goes to the giants and as far as
you know maybe the the giants are
researching the possibility of trading
for a josh rosen that tells me that
they're not absolutely in love with the
other two quarterbacks not named kyler
murray that i talked about in the first
round which is drew locke and dwayne
haskins so that tells me that also i
want to make sure everybody knows out
there you know this whole josh rosen i'm
going to get traded all that stuff thing
it's not necessarily an indictment on
josh rosen i still believe that he has
potential to be a really good nfl
starting quarterback i mean he was the
most accurate
thrower of the football coming out in
the draft last year yeah his arm wasn't
as strong as baker mayfield's or josh
allen's but it was stronger than sam
darnold and he throws a very
what i would say a catchable ball mike
he's a perfect spiral thrower uh and
there is something to that but he's a
good decision maker he's a smart kid and
he's and he's pure throwing the football
that's what i would say about him and
just because arizona might want to trade
him it's not an indictment on him it's
more about the specialness of kyla
murray and the skill set he brings
that's very rare in the history of the
nfl
joel klatt was on undisputed on fox
sports one on
wednesday and he said that the
patriots giants and chargers are the
three teams that i have heard and i know
are very interested in rosen one of
those is already offered a second round
pick according to rose and arizona is
waiting for her first and you know i
remember thinking at one point early on
when this train was starting to move in
the direction of the cardinals taking
kyler murray and trading josh rosen that
rosen may feel compelled at some point
to leak something that makes him look
better in all of this and this makes him
look better at a time when it feels like
the cardinals don't want him here's
three teams who do patriots giants
chargers somebody's already willing to
have a second round pick for this guy i
i think that
you you know people get uncomfortable
when we try to speculate on who their
sources are but this is a reason why i'm
giving credence to klatt's report yeah
because i i think it it it doesn't take
many steps to trace it right back to
rosen yes i agreed with you yeah i
totally do uh he you know he was around
of course sam darnold josh rosen a lot
last year during the draft process you
know we've talked about fox sports being
there in southern california he's
connected to the college scene there i
would be shocked if he didn't get this
someone very close to rosen altogether
and the three teams you mentioned there
that joe joel is mentioning they make
sense i mean just from a pure football
standpoint yes the giants new england
gosh would they give away the 30-second
pick for josh rosen uh maybe i would
certainly think about it you know
especially if you go man this is this is
the last year for tom or at least the
second of last year of tom
and the chargers certainly have to start
thinking about the future as well
because i think you know philip rivers
is certainly on the way down he's
playing good i know all of that but
it's not like the phillip rivers we saw
five six years ago
here's the one key thing to consider
contractually too if you inherit josh
rosen's contract first as we've
previously mentioned the cardinals have
paid the bulk of the money in signing
bonus and first year salary you get him
for three years had a total of like 6.2
million or something like that however
that fourth year which will be the fifth
year option because he was picked number
10 and not pick number 11 you're in a
different stratosphere for what you'd
have to pay him for the fifth year
option it becomes the transition tag for
quarterbacks in the year before that
fifth year option operates which for
this year marcus mariota and james
winston 20.8 million one pick lower it's
a much lower number so that's something
if you're gonna plan this like bill
belichick will and he plans everything
you have to be thinking what that
50-year option payment would be and it's
a bigger number because he was number
10. if he's one spot lower everything
changes it's amazing how all that
happens chris but you know look it feels
like it's all moving in this direction
who knows what ultimately is going to
happen i think the nfl wants the
cardinals to keep it all close to the
vest as long as possible and that brings
up a point that you and i have discussed
previously and i'm very intrigued about
where you stand on this right now
because the off-season programs are
opening soon if you are one of these
teams do you want rosen now or are you
content to wait until the draft and your
pick is on the clock because if you're
the cardinals you want that pick when
it's on the clock you don't want teams
to know that here you are with your pick
because they start trying to guess what
you're going to do and maybe leapfrog
yeah no definitely i i think the thing
that it's it's not crucial that it gets
done you know or i say this it's not
crucial that josh rosen gets there
before the draft and all of that you
know what what is it the date that
players are allowed to go back and work
out is it april 15th is that the date
we're at right now in the nfl basically
it's earlier than for the for the
cardinals it's earlier than that for you
if you're a new coach it's uh right
around the first or early part there's a
there's a lag for new coaching staffs
and uh and holdovers but but regardless
if you if you have this guy you want him
in there as soon as possible you don't
want to wait until the draft no you you
do you want him in there as soon as
possible of course it's the quarterback
position is very important but at the
same time i don't think you're going to
make any stupid decisions or rush to
anything over two or three weeks of time
and josh rosen is no dummy i think he
can pick up an offense uh fairly quickly
uh so i wouldn't you know i wouldn't
think teams make that too much of a
deciding factor knowing they'll be able
to play catch-up you know after the
draft is really when a lot of the
offseason groundwork gets laid as far as
team team you know meetings uh otas
minicamps all of that where he can get
the heavy lifting and catch up for
whatever team he does play on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports